he's Tony reallying former stat boy what
does that boy over the Stepway but he
hosts the ESPN sports debate and
discussion show called around the horn
is that what that is I see somebody
should have told me that I've been 14
years ago
it's the debate and discussion show
Monday through Friday at 5:00 Eastern
how long have you been hosted yeah
February of Oh four is when I took over
around the horn when I'm filled in for
around the horn so that was uh that's
going on this is our 13th 14th season of
that how old were you
25 at that time I think maybe just
turned 26 recently big pretty big it was
it was it was enormous it was I can tell
you from the suit I wore that day which
was the only suit I had it was drenched
in sweat with with with pangs of fear I
mean I think that was a big day that was
the day after the Super Bowl
I just teased it you know it was the day
after the Patriots Panther Super Bowl it
was a day after Janet Jackson's boob was
introduced the entire world and that's
the show I fill in as a Harry I mean I'm
a 26 year old is gonna talk a Janet
Jackson's breast was where in the show
that I'm sure we led with the game and
then did Janet Jackson's breasts all
said that was a 2 a 2 for probably about
five minutes and Here I am I mean that
was the first breath I've ever seen so
so for me to be able to process all that
it was it was a big show and that was my
first one so it's a memorable one and
saying that I don't remember any second
of it because I was so scared
imagine if Janet Jackson Justin
Timberlake happened now
yeah social media yeah yeah I think I
mean I mean it was a big deal then yeah
DC was looking into it for months I mean
at some point we fatigued they were like
all right we got it you know it's a boob
that was what Mike will bug said on PTI
the next day our children what are you
going to tell you about Matt he was
bored at that point so we didn't have he
didn't have little bond what are you
gonna tell your children if there's a
boob on national TV son that is a boob
let's watch the game you know I mean
that's that remember Wilmont saying that
but but sure especially in today's uh
today's climate I think as we'd like to
say what podium weren't your kids at
thinking yes they were
scarred for life they're scarred but no
my son was fascinated by it um I don't
know how old he was so he was probably
12 he's by 13 yeah but you know just the
fact that it happened yeah and then he
wanted to ask if somebody was going to
get in trouble
well he was yeah I mean that was his did
anybody get in trouble I don't think so
right nobody really got in trouble and
and Janet Jackson took the brunt of that
which is just the very odd thing to
think back 15 years it's someone else
did CBS KITT was it as revealed a breath
I think CBS got find something 125 grand
or something for that oh yeah I remember
that too I remember being six figures
for a broadcast that I had 100 million
people watching did you ever doubt
though if you could do around the world
like oh for sure yeah I had doubt I mean
I was a sidekick on the best show on the
network yeah and that's 10 seconds of
air time of day it would sound like I
was doing I mean heavy lifting I was
doing 10 seconds of air time of day and
I was just enjoying being around Tony
and Mike which for me was you know
that's something that was enjoyable and
and what we were doing on air we were
doing off air for eight hours before we
did the show how did you get that job
instead boy I wanted to be you I wanted
to be Mike Breen I think even a little
bit before that you want to do high
level s yeah and I went to Fordham
University which growing up in this area
the guy who called the Yankees the guy
called the Knicks the guy who called the
Giants the guy who called the Nets all
went to Fordham simple choice I wasn't
going anywhere else and my broadcast
partner at Fordham at the time was was
very very good the first time I heard
him I was like okay I guess I can do it
something else of Speer adidas who's now
yes calling the March Madness games
calling CBS game so that that's who I'm
rolling with and he's doing back around
the rim meal away we're going left to
right on the radio dial and I'm just
like doing stand-up material in the
middle of a bit I mean I was a little
bit too much personality for lack of a
better word in the middle of a radio
call that's not working you know yeah
yeah
so I'm crowd work I'm grab doing crowd
work in the middle of it I mean there's
no crowd so so I think in the end and
you know who Laura our play-by-play
mentor was Marty Glickman
Oh legendre so I'm at Fordham I've got
guys out the wazoo who are doing
national and local big big games I've
got marty glickman telling me anthony
with that voice you're never going to be
able play-by-play man cuz mom's from
Brooklyn dad's from Manhattan and Staten
Island born and stand-on raised in
Jersey that is the armpit of accents as
bad as you get at the fast-forward I
mean ESPN I worked with the voice coach
for a little while so you hear what
you're hearing what comes out though
there's certain words oh yeah I mean
well I mean what was it for me I mean my
life will do anything that was yeah yeah
I think anything ends in ER it's a real
troublesome thing for me I go over water
or something like that yeah but I mean I
think I've lost it I mean I lived in DC
for a while too um but I get I get at a
position opening with Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire spinoff on sports which is
the two-minute drill hosted by Kenny
main all right so that's my entree into
an to ESPN I wrote I research for the
first season and wrote trivia questions
for a living how great a job is that
it's dream job number two actually
because at Fordham I was covering the
Yankees in 1998 1999 and 2000 so I saw
three World Series covering the Yankees
as a student reporter for a public radio
station that was professional you know
so I had those two experiences early on
and there's no turning back when you had
that but writing trivia questions for
Kenny main show which is a really cool
experience because you guys ever see
quiz show the movie in really really
good movies yeah my that stuff kind of
still applied in 2001 trivia as you know
there's Nate it was fixed
well no but there was a propriety laws
or propriety laws however it works I
walked into Kenny main once and it was
just like sirens were going off like I
could not talk to him in any way pass on
a question to him our desks had paper
shredders every night your desk kind of
looked like this when you left it's kind
of cool
I kind of dug that how would you do on
sports jeopardy there was a time in my
life that nobody would be being me I
think that my mid-20s you know this is
this is what amounts to somebody who
never went on a date in high school
again you know Janet Jackson's boy was
my first but only
would like a piece you you want a piece
of me I want a couple I wanna do this
man we do this later we do this
community after hour maybe we could do
it out there next time we do sports
jeopardy maybe yeah are you are you a
good in the bar having some beers trivia
guy because I'm here's a tough one for
me because as you can see I'm a half a
human to begin with with you this is
what I was talking about this so this is
a beautiful creation here that Dan
drinks that has apple banana kale I
don't know what acorn acorn you have
acorn in here what is a cm I have known
okay you wish maybe he's drinking acorns
he might be part squirrel and and
spinach so for me for a while I was
drinking these on a daily basis now the
amount of spinach you need okay if you
order spinach fritzy you're getting
spinach with your meal every night of
the state all right yeah so on your
plate there's this much spinach the
amount of spinach you need to fill out a
a juice it is like this much spinach
that's a whole lot if you're listening
on radio again I'm a TV guy oh baby got
ya so my point is they show you Popeyes
muscles they don't show you is kidney
stones I had kidney stones because I
would drink one or two of these a day
from my healthy lifestyle and after that
and combined in a few food poisonings
from maybe a delectable dish of sushi
from the Pittsburgh Airport what
happened with that you you threw up into
I maintained any sushi you've ever eaten
in your life unless you're in Tokyo okay
it's coming from a plane somewhere it's
just it's being flown in you're not
fishing at a Lake Michigan if you live
in wherever the middle of the country
wherever live never just caught a fish
and then a hand up like a fish and made
sushi and just like that although I have
not done that what am I an adventurer
Lewis and Clark here like East River you
never liked the ice river your francesca
saw them pull a fish out of the Hudson
job just last week like this big is like
oh my goodness throughout there so I'm
in Pittsburgh I'm flying out to go to go
to do a bike race in California which I
don't do either I think my bike shorts
at the time I know this were women's
bike shorts
because you go you buy bike shorts for
the first time you don't know where the
padding's supposed to be you know
there's supposed to be padding we don't
know there's where it's supposed to be
so I bought these and then I I looked in
the back the tag was pink but I thought
okay this is stylistically you know I
mean there's a pink jersey in the Tour
de France so I mean and then and then
the side said something like six as I go
okay a size six is this European fit or
something like that I wore size six for
women for my bike short so III was
equipped with women's bike shorts and I
was flying out to LA for this race from
maybe San Diego to some you know
something below the border and I was
like I got to eat healthy going into
this and it's you're at an airport
what are you gonna get nice so the sushi
stain I'm like I'll get some sushi you
know it's nice clean living let's do
that so I had sushi at the Pittsburgh
air I think it was the Rust Belt roll
which which initially some suspicion for
some people but not this guy and it was
serious like a circle of hell man that
was bad that was bad what not the worst
I think muscles from Brussels was the
worst you had muscles in Brussels oh
yeah yeah which should make sense it
rhymes and I known for their Mira Sophie
fairing people there's Ryder they're
known for John Claude Van Damme I was
expecting him to deliver them actually
at the table um that was the worst one I
was in a we were staying and this is me
and my wife who was I think my wife at
the time we were staying in some sort of
bed-and-breakfast hotel mansion women
the only people there it was the you
know six here's a knoll this is an old
European city and it's in its this is
what you want out of life right and I
think they had heated floors in the
bathroom which you're like well this is
pretty cool when you take a shower your
toesies warm when you get out of shower
now I see now I see the benefits of a
heated floor in a bathroom when you are
vomiting protectively and your spleen is
coming in your body and you're just
there's nothing in the world more
comfortable than underneath the toilet
seat when you're in that moment it's
really early in the morning for people
really want to hear this I just did yeah
yeah we're going to take a break Tony
reality is in the building I just I need
you to have a little bit more energy
though when we
okay people doing it we wanted to play
around the horn oh good let's do this
but I want you we already have the
topics but I want you to decide how many
points planets get let's go I'll go
around the horn and also I want to know
when it was real friction on around the
horn yeah is there any topic that
created friction any anytime you've ever
come close to a fight or anybody be
angry at one another like I want me to
think about this you will get maybe an
answer right it's called a tease
oh yeah that's right that's what you're
doing okay you tease around the horn
stuff right I you know what we kind of
got rid of that what you did because I
tease at the top of the show but but
what I determined was I'm gonna just jam
as much I'm going to break like this
see you later I'll be back okay all
right then see you later we'll be back
to magic show
what's the full question today McLovin
for tony reali the host of around the
horn we haven't decided on one the
leader in the clubhouse is tonight a
must-win situation for Cleveland
Cavaliers or are you allowed to say that
as a sports fan or is a to stupid of a
question tonight a must must way now is
a mute worthy and Fraxel yeah yeah yeah
what else will get you muted um the word
elite goalie standing on his head at
this point especially with a lot of the
panel's I throw out there not a lot of
coverage of hockey from my panel or
maybe and the greater sphere that we're
on so that happened yesterday to Kate
Fagan and some there was some static
coming back from that not from Kate Kate
would never give me static but from some
people how could you possibly view her
for a brilliant well no I've heard that
197 times
so so that's out there right now
narrative um is something that I've had
to mute the optics the opposite of
saying narrative is very bad yes really
problematic
Tony how about it someone finishes with
at the end of the day or to a man yeah I
don't mind at the end of the day or
having said that because that harkens me
to a place I can go which is Curb Your
Enthusiasm
having said that to me okay now I can
get into a curvy enthusiasm
and basically I'm doing the entire show
only to rip into Goodfellas or Seinfeld
or some of the other things that I like
yeah do you play favorites um I play
favorites not in the people they are
play favorites in the style and delivery
and how they're doing it I guess you're
trying to ask me how does one score
around the board okay subjective it is
something I have accrued for many years
fine set of skills some might say I
judge them on point of view I think most
of all I want somebody who's bringing
something that's their own I want style
and information and delivery and of
course I want accuracy I'm your true for
anything inaccurate especially I catch
in real time I live for those moments
where I see them walking themselves into
something and I also Muta to penalize
and direct traffic because we've got
four voices and as you know from
watching a TV there are four different
locations which is a cool thing that we
do but also can get a little hairy
sometimes when there's a slight delay
coming out of out of LA now I think the
delay is coming out of LA it may be
coming out of Jay adonde image a Adhan
delay I had never gotten really tense
like seriously where somebody criticized
there were a time there was a time when
and it tells you how long ago it was
where I would get off the set and there
would be a blinking light on an
answering machine on my desk phone so
that would be a blinking light and I
would look at it I would see the area
code and it would be from Chicago Jay
Mariani modern Chicago one of our many
many and it would say message three
minutes and seven seconds and I was like
what did I get myself into I want every
panelists to have some competitive vigor
I want them to attack with deft aplomb I
want I think when I took over the show
you asked me if I was nervous I was
especially nervous because I was young
and because I had one suit and two ties
um but I was also nervous because you
know the show was made for Max Kellerman
the first host and Max and I are similar
in a lot of ways but he also wants to
kind of lead with his chin a little bit
you know he doesn't mind putting it out
there I think the show started with
these four things I know are true that's
not something I'm going to
say never felt comfortable coming out of
my mouth I think I said it for the first
50 episodes and kind of begged off of
that and we kind of be mated about the
sports writers you're looking at four of
America's most socially you know awkward
sports writers and now we've made it
just about you know the tease but I kind
of what got us away from the blinking
light phone call you know and anything
else that kind of came out and there's
never really been a bad moment to answer
your question because I'm somebody who
will force communication I'm somebody
will force feelings among people I am
uncomfortable with my feelings if you're
uncomfortable with my feelings I'm
comfortable with that you know I I flew
out and I met with everybody which is
how the first time I've been in the Dan
Patrick airspace the only time in my
life and Paul was there too was after
our roads for Dan Patrick and I was with
Jay Mariotti at the time this was in
Chicago the first time I've ever been to
Chicago when I landed I thought I woke
up I thought I fell asleep in a plane I
woke up and I looked outside I thought
I'd landed in LA I did not realize Lake
Michigan was like a big hilarity of
order late like well late to me is like
I'm gonna skip some stones in the lake
and maybe hit the other side of the lake
right I can throw a baseball over Lake
Michigan sure like education wasn't too
big in your household go I think I was
educated and other things of it I action
magic oh yeah and that's mess I'm good
in world geography I'd like this you
know the Atlantic is big too yeah yeah
have you ever been told you look like
David Blaine David Blaine a little bit
Andy Pettitte a lot yeah and I like the
Andy Pettitte if you put up the baseball
glove yes I got over honey eyes oh and I
loved Andy Pettitte and then there's
also a little bit of a francesca
Schiavoni who's a Italian tennis player
and and I believe her family's from the
same part of Italy that my family is so
I got that going for me and then I think
my Twitter pinned tweet at this moment
which was a sentence never said in
history until I just said it right now
is Ruth Bader Ginsburg and Marlon Wayans
which which proves to you I can go I can
go everywhere if you need me to I can
really get you a man who can do you both
look at it look at it right now wait you
look like Ruth Bader great at at certain
time in my life it was my first
communion my First Holy Communion Dan
and I at the time had two glasses that
Janome Indians looking at better first
yeah 100% now go give me another way
into give me Marlon Wayans Oh so get you
a man that can do you both and that's
all that's that's my code man that's how
I live my life all right let me let me
do it around the horn and I will give
you the topic and then the damage will
give you their aunt and I will score now
how long are they allowed to talk well
typically we say about 15 to 20 I'm
gonna give you guys 10 seconds because I
believe we're dealing with a higher
caliber of competitive banter or oh okay
all right here we go best-looking
quarterback in New England that's a good
question that might be buyers still
wandering around the one today
okay uh Paulie all right let's go around
or Paulie I'm ready to go present tense
question you know it's a question is it
in the past it's in present tense we're
not talking about ability legacy history
just looks it's Jimmy Garoppolo done
because you had to qualify it with an
enormous the preamble was longer than
our own government's based on go ahead
oh we got McLovin let's hit it come on
okay Jimmy G has that whole sexy pirate
thing going on I get it but Tom Brady is
a classic I think we get got bored of
how good-looking was but I've been
flipping through the Met Ball pictures
he's an all-timer the eyes as blue as
ever Tom Brady ding ding ding all right
let's go pretty Jimmy Garoppolo Tom
Brady overrated we get all caught up
that he's got the Gisele supermodel
lifestyle and wife overrated baller
cliche ding ding OH
cheatin winning looks good doesn't it if
there's only one man in New England I
want to see standing shirtless under a
waterfall and it's Tom Brady you won't
you forgot one thing play to your hosts
go up below if you would have known
where his ancestry was fry man you play
does not does not convey in a normal way
should I should I play that up a little
bit more the coolest player in the NBA
okay thanks around the horn scene let's
go back the other way come on Oh John
Wall absolutely close dude he's all
tatted out dougie
enough said all tatted out is we're
giving credit for all set it out that's
everybody in the league go ahead
Christie
draymond Green always smiling
got a little bit of an edge to him isn't
afraid to break somebody's shoulder we
need people in the gonads
go ahead McLovin I'm gonna go with the
veil McGee can anyone else right a
headband like the veil McGee Paul as
well now I've seen this face before
somebody said exactly what you're about
to say Pablo completely eyeball let's
see you vamp I'm gonna go with JaVale
McGee here's why because I don't know
what's going to happen when he steps on
the court he's going to dunk on your
basket on our basket on their baskets
probably great gonna happen ding ding
ding a lot of voids for the guy love his
mom Pam McGee yes yet Ben McGee gets
credit to one other I throw out there
just to wrap up here because we were
talking about the best duo's in NBA
history this week with with Duran and
curry
dion Waiters and anyone on a 10 game
contract best duo in NBA history all
right best hair in sports media history
I'm not allowed to be in oh I can't I
have to exclude myself here so we'll go
around the horn falling Mel Kiper jr.
it's a legend from day one of the draft
of the day of the drafting day it's like
the Mount Rushmore ham ding ding ding oh
man ding ding McLovin I'm gonna go with
Michelle Beadle I don't know if you're
lively hi I love Michelle and honestly I
feel like if she was on around the horn
everyone a show of Michelle Beadle would
be like run and hide situation every
other panelists that day so I'll give
you a ding ding fritzy I am not ashamed
to admit a man crush on Jim Palmer back
in the day and agency great hair
underwear though there's hair there
wasn't just hair on the head right I
mean I mean every day
that was burlap by the UH okay let's go
let me know where because I didn't say
just hit on your hair right hand very
generous right yeah that's not a c-note
Connor I think probably the most
underappreciated head of hair in sports
media history Seton Hall guy won the
general Robert Aloysius Lee guys had the
exactly absolutely Bob Lee the guy's got
a solid head of hair and nobody talks
about is a hair part you could set your
watch hasn't moved in forty what he does
if he straps that on in the morning mean
that's just a piece that it goes okay
okay yeah I've seen him put it on it
looks damn I was gonna go john clayton
with the ponytail no and that's the way
jolly good time sweetie had going not
going out Johnny it's got a good son uh
he hosts around the horn by the way it's
a sports debate and discussion our David
remember now Friday Monday through
Friday at five Eastern you're always
welcome back here you are very much mean
and I just agree we had to it's not a
full invite but you're always welcome
back okay
we'd love to have you missus always
already looks like my my bedroom if you
got posters of Goodfellas in Scarface up
there you notice that there's a typo in
the scarf its poster time to find out
what we messed up stat boy they have a
typo in the Scarface poster why do you
love Goodfellas so much why is that even
a question why it's cinematically
perfect what are you talking about
it's okay anything was Frank fast it's
really is gone it's he's up he's gone
taken the heated with spinach
you're taking language maybe what do you
do
good move better that is the correct
move Tony
rallies going around the corner here and
leaving all right we're back after this
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience